um a couple things I just wanted to
point out before I I come to you so
inside the bill it's $60 billion do in
Ukraine Aid $4 billion for Israel 10
billion in humanitarian Aid 5 billion
for our indopacific partners that leaves
20 billion for the
borders both North and South that's not
a border bill look you know I have spent
so much of my time in the last three
years covering the border and in talking
to all of the agents from the the
ranking file all the way up to the
senior leadership they're not happy with
this and any agent will tell you sure
we'd love more money but what we really
need Beyond money Manpower technology is
we need some policy to change and to
walk back the way we got into this
problem is that this Administration uh
favored a cash and release process that
had no consequences and when you hear
members of Congress talk about their
already laws on the books you do title 8
USC 1325 they'll tell you simply makes
it a felony to cross the border now
you're in a situation where one early
this morning at before 5:00 a.m. my
phone was dinging at 4:30 in the morning
and clearly agents are getting up an
agent that's down on the border said
this seems to me to send a message to
the world that says come on down we're
letting in 4,999 a day now Senator
langford's arguing that there's a lot of
good stuff in this bill and that that's
not the case that's being misinterpreted
but at the same time you see things
language like that and you worry Why
didn't it address things like the actual
laws currently on the book and and move
to a remain in Mexico policy which makes
everyone who wants to claim asy you can
walk at any time of the day to a legal
Port of Entry and claim Asylum and you
may or may not get past pass the initial
interview but the process of Crossing
illegally in mass and declaring Asylum
and being paroled into the US is a new
problem the country has had that began
under this Administration and that
fundamental part of the crisis is what
every border official is saying has got
to change and that doesn't seem to
change in this by the way one more point
if you think for a moment the cartels
won't choose to find another way to
exploit it and go to a metering system
to bring their numbers down I'm sure
they're already on it tell me think
again yeah they're already on that CU
they know that we're going to have to do
something eventually maybe it'll be
under a Republican president but but
they know some change has to be coming
even if it's this what the the Democrats
put out you know Kaylee it's the numbers
game it's the shell game that is so
disingenuous and people really have to
look at this they're stuck on the 5,000
number I'm stuck on
8,500 cuz that also is supposed to
trigger something but it's a 7day
average so if you have 8,500 on one one
day but you have a thousand on the next
day because you put some attention there
your average is going to be lower I mean
this is a shell game and again the
cartels already know this yeah to your
point the worry about the cartels gaming
the system that's a really interesting
point look bottom line here so much is
being said about this bill we have a
derelict Lawless president there are
laws on the book in the immigration and
nationality act you just cited some
federal laws that our president is
choosing not to enforce we have a
president who decided to light the
border on fire that is what he did in
his first 100 days 94 executive actions
to roll away the Trump erab border
policies we are here not because of a
lack of a compr comprehensive
immigration reform we are here because
we have a president who simply doesn't
care who enables people coming across
our border who enables the cartels who
enables the human traffickers that is
the problem not the lack of a bill now
Senator Langford would say this puts a
mandatory activation requirement on a
lawless president I heard him make that
argument so that part is true but we
have a president who disregards the law
we have a president who cuts down razor
wire in Texas so until you fix the guy
at the top the executive Joe Biden you
don't fix the problem I I want to hear
real quickly from congresswoman Kat
kamik of Florida on last hour on the
focus she had this to say about the
bill this is not a border security
package this is a Ukraine package this
is aid for Palestinians package this is
uh assistance to Arab Partners package
this is not border security this is a
way for them to parole people into the
United States faster you are not
securing the Border in this package and
we would do well not to lie to the
American people and try to sell them on
that they already are pissed Molly I see
you nodding well it's very interesting
to hear cat kamik talk this way because
what I'm hearing from various people on
both the house and the Senate side is
Extreme anger about Republican
participation in this border package you
saw you know Joe Biden said please pass
this bill Chuck Schumer said this is a
great Bill my orcus currently about to
be impeached for mishandling the Border
says this is a great Bill what people
don't understand is what were
Republicans having to do with this Chuck
Schumer also said he has never worked so
closely on any piece of legislation with
Mitch McConnell as this package and it
shows because it doesn't actually do
anything on the border but it does give
$60 billion to Ukraine Mitch McConnell
said that's the most important policy
priority for Republican voters I think
Republican voters have responded to that
by showing why he is the least popular
politician in this country so it's kind
of a watershed moment for Republicans
like they don't have a lot of power in
the Senate but they do have Mitch
McConnell who's supposed to be very good
at negotiating this stuff he puts
Langford in who completely gets rolled
sorry but he does and you're not seeing
you know you see Steve Dan saying this
is an electoral disaster for Republicans
it doesn't make sense that a party that
wants to win or lead the country would
participate in this and that's why
you're seeing it Dead on Arrival in the
house but also not seeing a lot of
Republican Senators sign I also that the
kitchen sink element of it is so obvious
right to your point so Washington Post
for example is touting this as saying
well this would be the most
comprehensive immigration reform passed
in decades funny how it seemed to happen
just a couple months before the
presidential election so exactly to your
point all they're interested in is
having that headline be put forth and
having that box be checked right what's
interesting to me and I want viewers to
understand this because I think these
two points are important the first is
that it moves Asylum claim decisions
away from immigration judges and instead
into the hands of just Asylum claim
officers and here's why that yes exactly
and the second point about that that I
think it it shows a second message think
about if um if you were getting heart
surgery and obviously you would want
your heart in the hands of an
experienced heart surgeon but you know
what if there's a bomb and that goes off
all you want we just need hands we just
need hands to triage we just need
everyone to stop the bleeding so what
used to be a very credible and very um
sacred system in this country
immigration the concept that people
would take their citizenship and
applications to live here so seriously
and that we take it so seriously too
that's the honor that we Accord it now
oh we just need hands here you guys here
you step in it's a great Point can I
weigh in on that because the first
interview I ever did with Alejandra my
orcz was when he was the director of
USCIS so you're taking the decision on
deciding a claims adjudicating claims
away from immigration judges and an ice
prosecutor and putting it in the hands
of a USCIS person that's what this bill
know it's going to happen now and when I
interviewed my orchus at the USCIS we
finished the interview at the Library of
Congress when he was swearing in new
citizens and I asked him at the time
this all on camera if you go back 10
plus years I said how do people that are
getting sworn in becoming citizens right
now in this moment feel about those that
skip the line come illegally he said oh
they're very angry yeah and I it's just
an interesting change in the way the
view the the public views these things I
I want to get Donald Trump's voice in
here former president Donald Trump spoke
with Maria bomo about the crisis at the
southern border and who really is coming
across let's watch
together going have to deport a lot of
them it's not sustainable and now you
look look these countries are very smart
I know every one of the leaders of the
countries for the most part uh the
presidents the dictators I know them all
I know the Kings the Queens I know them
all these are smart people these are
StreetWise people it makes sense that
they're taking people out and sending
them up in Caravans to the United States
and it's not just South America it's
from Africa from Asia from all over the
world as yeah I mean from all over the
world from China there had 28,000 people
in the last few months 28,000 that's
what's he doing building an army and
they were mostly men almost all men from
the age of 18 to 25 so what's that all
about so what's interesting too about
what the president is saying even if
this bill were to pass in in any form
you and I both know that it would take
years to put any sort of Asylum process
whether it's tougher whether it's a
shorter period together I mean years so
why isn't it being talked about and what
have you heard on the hill about just
stopping it now just shut the border
down now maybe a year maybe only 90 days
and what I'm hearing back is Democrats
wouldn't even entertain the idea that it
was Dead on Arrival so to speak and I'm
hearing we don't have the resources of
the the mechanisms to start doing they
can't shut down the border so why is it
in this bill that they think that they
can shut down the border on a moment's
notice when 8,500 people cross the board
that's a debate we hope we hear and by
the way the other part of this is that
that uh there's concerns from officials
that as soon as this were to get passed
if it were you would have PR migrant
groups sue the arbitrary number to try
and stop its implementation absolutely
all right boy well this will continue
because they haven't even gotten to the
point now where they're negotiating in
the house if that happens hey everyone
I'm Emily compano catch me and my
co-hosts Harris vulner and Kaye mcki on
outnumbered every weekday at 12:00 p.m.
Eastern or sets your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights